one service that um that i'll
talk to you about for a minute um
the gentleman was kia
and that's military terminology for
killed in action
but he was killed in action
in world war ii so he dies in world war
ii in the battle of bataa
he is buried over there
on the where in a cemetery that they
basically buried all the troops that got
killed right there
he's buried there oh yeah but face style
they put a bunch of them in one spot
you know they would just dig graves they
and they had this protocol that they did
and they had government-issued raincoats
and they'd wrap the body up in the
raincoat and they'd bury it
and then they'd move on to their next
battle or whatever
well there's organizations out there
that are going through and trying to
find
all these soldiers and bring them back
to their homes
wow so sure enough i get a call from a
family
and they have been in touch with one of
these organizations and they have found
the remains of a guy from our town
at that at bataa
so what they did was they disinterred
his body and flew it to hawaii and
in hawaii they matched the dna
for him to one of his nieces
they matched that dna to confirm that it
was him
and then we started making the
arrangements
to get him back here so of course they
they booked the flight and they said
okay he's going to arrive
in nashville at such and such day at
such and such time
so you guys show up at the airport so we
show up at the airport with the family
and everything else
meet with the airport police at
nashville
and where do they come through baggage
come it's a large item like the golf bag
well they they they travel underneath
they travel underneath on the plane
but um when i was dealing with the
airline
um the airline's like
now what's going to happen is we're
going to go out there
and we're going to bring his body here
and you can
you know the family can receive the body
at the tar you know here at baggage
claim
or actually it's kind of like air cargo
oh yeah
and um and then the head of the
airport police he showed up and i and i
started talking to him he said he said
these are the cargo people
he said i'm in charge he said you want
to go out to meet the plane
i said yeah i want to go out to meet the
plane he said well put everybody in your
vehicles and we'll go out and meet the
plane
and so they brought airport vans and
everything else and we went
we drove the hearst and everything out
to the tarmac
wow they brought they brought the you
know
because we had we had this was
pre-covered so we had a full detail
of our of you know a farming men there
and they received
the casket you know right off the plane
carried him to the hearse
and it was you know it was a big deal
you know real emotional
they had everybody in the um
in the area and like in the terminal
come to the glass windows
and they all watched it and they were
all holding flags and everything else
as they took as they brought the body to
the hearse
and then after that then we brought him
all the way back
from out of the tarmac back to
hopkinsville and how big was he well
they had him in a full-sized casket oh
damn
because what they did was they crossed
some large
they chronicled everything that they had
and you believe it was really him or not
i do they had they had it down to they
had
every one of his bones except for one
they had it all laid out they had
all the dna they had everything about
him they had in this book that they gave
to the families and everything else
we um so we're coming back you know
we've got police escorts all the way
from nashville
all the way you know to to the kentucky
state line
and that's when the tennessee people
broke off and then when we got to
christian county
the sheriff's department was there
waiting on us and i bet you they had
about eight
units there and then when we got to the
city of hopkinsville
the city was there and the community
came out big for it
and the fire truck you know they took
the back big boom ladder and everything
else
and they had a huge american flag draped
that we drove under and everything else
and we took him out to uh [ __ ]
we took him out to the local cemetery
that
his that his parents were buried at all
his brothers were buried there
and we buried him there i mean we even
had the pgr there
and um you know the pgr is another group
that we work with occasionally
and what they are is they're called
they're the patriot guard riders
and they're motorcycle guys and most of
them are veterans and everything else
but they really got a lot of notoriety
back when there was that group from
kansas that was going around
protesting military funerals you could
call the pgr
and they'd show up and they would show
up and so what they would do is they
would ride their motorcycles
you know with the funeral and when like
if
you were coming up to the cemetery or
whatever and there was
the protesters they'd stopped right
there and the protesters
in front of the protesters and rev those
motorcycles up
you drive right on by and you never
could he'll hear the protesters wow
and so that's really magical people come
out to support veterans you know yeah it
means a lot to people
uh especially to those families
especially getting to be back with your
family i think have you
you know just have your rest in place
back with their families something
beautiful about that good evening good
afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah